this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks net thanks for that great
introduction so today I will be
presenting on my thesis research
developing perennial grain cropping
systems and market opportunities in the
Northeast I'd like to start with a few
acknowledgments I would first and
foremost like to acknowledge the land on
which this research was conducted and
Cornell University operates for
thousands of years has been the
traditional land of the Hyuga nation
members of the hood nashoni Confederacy
today the summe place is still home to
the Keoghan
and other indigenous peoples from across
Turtle Island and I'm grateful for the
opportunity to work on this layer I'd
also like to acknowledge some of the
people that have been quite important in
conducting this research I wouldn't have
been able to do this all on my own
so recognizing Chris Pelzer Sandra
Wayman Scott Morris the text for the
sustainable cropping systems and weed
ecology and management labs and all
their contributions cindy Bartel who's a
postdoc in the sustainable cropping
systems lab has been collaborating with
me on many of these projects and some of
our undergraduate assistants and interns
only a couple of them from this year but
there have been many many that have
contributed to this work and I'll also
acknowledge them by name at the end so
just to let you know what we're gonna be
talking about today we'll start with
discussing perennial grains and why
we're interested in them why we're
studying them why they're important for
sustainable cropping systems development
well then talk about thinking in a
systems approach how can you consider
not just the growth of grain or a forage
not just the interactions with weeds and
diseases in the ecosystem not just
economics not just sustainability but
all of those things together how they
interact to create a system that can
have either beneficial or detrimental
properties I'll then discuss my research
objectives for my thesis talk about a
few of the preliminary results we've
seen over the last and then discuss
briefly some future work or continuation
of work on the
projects so why grow perennials well
take a step back I think everybody here
is probably familiar with the imposing
food security issues of a growing
population changing climate changes in
diets and degradation of much of our
natural capital around the world that's
all sort of coming to a head at the same
time and causing a lot of concern about
how we're going to intensify crop
production to feed 9 or 10 billion
people without further degrading our
natural capital and preventing that from
being sustainable into the future so
here we have a diagram from Jonathan
Foley and and others that was published
in science that looks at the difference
between a natural ecosystem intensive
monoculture at cropland and then
cropland with restored ecosystem
services these bubble charts show sort
of the magnitude of some of the services
that are available from each of these
systems and you can see in a natural
ecosystem there are a lot of ecosystem
services that are available mediating
disease air and water quality carbon
sequestration a habitat for wildlife
biodiversity but it really doesn't give
you that much in terms of crop
production the food that we need to
survive in contrast an intensive
monoculture particularly of annuals
gives you a large amount of crop
production but not so much in the other
areas and in fact some have now started
to think that instead of it just being a
low amount of services available here
there's actually dis services in many of
these areas that are created by
intensive monocultures such as soil loss
water quality impairment the idea with
restoring ecosystem services to
agriculture which doesn't necessarily
need to be perennial but perennial
plants have been proposed to be part of
the solution is that you can still get
crop production maybe not necessarily
the exact magnitude of monoculture but
restore many of these other services and
therefore create a system that is more
functioning and more sustainable over
time
so then just to think about what it
means to be perennial I have the
definition from Webster's dictionary
here a plant persisting for several
years usually with new or Bhatia's
growth from aprende in part so we see
perennials throughout natural ecosystems
not as often in agriculture but in the
context of agriculture a perennial crop
is one that you plant and then harvest
in one year producing some amount of
product and then in the following year
it'll regrow without having to replant
retail do all those field operations and
other management's that are needed to
have an annual cropping system persist
and so the benefits of perennial as I
said there's fewer field operations less
tillage no seeding after that first year
there's soil protection and enhancement
you have crops in the ground year-round
there's erosion control there's also a
contribution of carbon back into the
soil by the deep rooting system reduced
tillage doesn't disturb the soil
structure or biotic community as much
water quality enhancement by preventing
the leaching of nutrients that often
occurs in annual cropping systems taking
advantage of the early and late season
growth that these crops can come up as
early as it warms in the spring and be
there late into the fall
photosynthesizing and putting down
energy to be used in the next year and
there's potential to grow them on areas
where you might not be able to grow an
annual crop like on a sloped land where
tillage would lead to extensive erosion
or in riparian areas where those
nutrient movements off-site are more of
an issue for water quality
our major drawbacks though in particular
lower yields so at this point some of
the perennial grain crops we are working
with are at about 25 to 60 percent of
what a comparable annual produces in
grains for a single year and part of
that is that there's some catching up we
need to do in terms of breeding these
perennials
we've been breeding annuals for
thousands of years and very intensively
for the last century or so and we've
only been working on perennials for in
about 40 40 years there's also some
inherent life history trade-offs that
have been theorized between a perennial
plant that is allocating more energy to
persistence than to reproduction that's
the one of the main benefits of an
annual but there is some thought that
artificial selection can overcome that
in the future there are also
restrictions to your options for
management in these systems you can't
rotate crops for example so that does
limit the ways that you can counteract
disease buildup in the system you also
can't cultivate for weed suppression so
some problematic weeds might be only
able to be dealt with through herbicides
and if those herbicides are not
compatible with the crop then you could
be limited in in your response to those
weeds but there is quite a lot of
interest in perennial grains at this
time in particular Patagonia provisions
in 2016 release long route kale which is
a beer that was brewed using Kearns ax
one of the perennial grains that we're
working with here and emphasizing in the
marketing of that product the
regenerative nature of the crop
production building soil protecting
natural resources and it was quite
successful this led to a further
interest from General Mills one of the
larger food industry firms and their
Cascadian farms organic division which
wants in court
turns into some of their products and
General Mills is even interested in
incorporating perennial grains into
their entire product line things like
Cheerios as part of their corporate
commitment to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
so they have donated money towards
research and they're very involved in
the research and development of these
crops so with that amount of industry
support there has been quite a increase
in the amount of research and other
activity in the perennial grains area
from our work here at Cornell we're
using two varieties of Freddy or grain
as I mentioned earlier Kern's a-- is a
fine opium intermedia more intermediate
wheat grass this is a domesticated wild
relative of annual wheat so there are
two main ways of developing a perennial
grain crop you can either domesticate a
wild perennial plant or you can
hybridize a current annual crop plant
with perennial relatives and try to
introduce those perennial genes so
Kearns Oh was domesticated actually
starting around this area in the 1980s
Peggy Wagner at the Rodale Institute in
collaboration with folks at the Big
Flats plant materials Center selected
intermediate wheatgrass is the most
promising of several hundred wild
perennial grasses that that were
screened and then did several cycles of
breeding and improvement there in work
towards a perennial grade in the early
2000s that germ plasm was transferred to
the Land Institute in Salina Kansas
where a breeding project has been in
place for the last two decades working
to develop what was eventually termed
Kearns ax which is the the most
productive of their varieties and has
now been used in commercial food
products we also have a Swan rye which
is sakali cereal so your annual rye butt
has been bred with a scaly strict a
mountain rye and then and then back
crossed to get some perennial genes into
that that rye this was originally
started the program was started in
Germany and then moved to agri-food
Canada Lethbridge Research Center where
it was the ACE one variety in particular
was created so now that we have these
crops there's a lot of interest from the
food industry there's a lot of interest
in the sustainable agricultural
community about them we have to figure
out how to grow them we also have to
figure out whether these ecosystem
services that people have been touting
are actually being realized and what's
the magnitude of those benefits in
practice we have to figure out how they
can fit into our current cropping
systems is this something that's gonna
be widespread adoption or is it really
going to be in those small niche areas
where you wouldn't be able to plant an
annual crop because of erosion control
for example and then how do they fit
into the food system if we produce these
grains and we need to figure out how we
can eat them for example Kearns ax does
not have the same gluten as wheat so
baking properties are much different the
same ace rye is a little bit more
similar to what you would do with an
annual radix it is I'm just a hybrid but
even figuring out whether perennial as a
value-added proposition similar to
organic produce is something that can
make these things more economic
economically viable needs to be
determined
so I didn't mention we're going to talk
about this from a systems perspective so
here we have a diagram of a typical
cropping system you have some natural
resources that are inputting energy and
material to the system you have some
purchased inputs soil amendments seed
fuel labor tools and then you have all
the interactions that are happening
within the boundaries of the system
itself interactions with soil and then
operations like tillage and planting
that create a a crop that is then
harvested and produces products
there's also interactions with other
species in the system non crop plants or
weeds pathogens and vertebrate pests
other animals that can contribute to
yield reduction
there's also the economic component of
assets of machinery and capital that are
integral to this whole the function of
it and so if we think about this in
terms of where perennial is going to
change this it's going to change the
soil because of reduced tillage it's
going to change some of these inputs
there's less planting there's less fuel
and labor going into those operations
the crop itself needs to be understood
and how its producing grain and and
potentially forage and the magnitude of
that and how to better optimize a system
we found recently that harvesting and
processing of these crops is not a
trivial matter they can behave quite
differently than what you would expect
with annuals for reasons like smaller
seed size adhering holes on the grain
they're not quite as free threshing as
the annuals that have been developed for
that purpose are and then in particular
the interactions with these pests and
pathogens in the system where you can't
use some of your typical management
tools that you would an annual system
needs to be studied oh and finally once
we get to this stage with crop products
where are we going to sell them for how
much that's a big question as well so
thinking about those things we have
developed five research objectives for
one of our projects at Musgrave research
farm we want to quantify agronomic
productivity of the two perennial grain
varieties we have understand the pest
dynamics assess impacts on soil health
and erosion potential estimate
break-even price points for the
perennial grains in comparison to
annuals and then evaluate the
system-wide environmental sustainability
of these systems using two different
metrics
I'll just go through a few slides where
we highlight the different parts of the
system that we're looking at for each of
these objectives so in terms of
agronomic productivity it really is at
the level of the crop plant and getting
those crop products that are what we're
hoping to produce with the system but
this does involve things I'm not in this
study particularly but there's so many
things that go into agronomic
productivity what's the row spacing
what's the seeding rate what's the
fertilization rate what's the harvesting
method what's the post harvest
processing so all of that is something
that needs to be considered before
perennial grains can become a bigger
part of our sustainable cropping systems
our second objective understanding pest
dynamics what species of weeds are going
to be most problematic what pathogens
are going to be infecting the the
perennial grains is it the same or is it
different than what we see on annual
grains and what's the magnitude and the
impact of these these pests on grain
productivity and grain quality we want
to look at soil health as one of the
main ecosystem services from that could
be realized from perennial grains we
want to quantify effects on physical
chemical and biological characteristics
of the soil we also want to better
understand the erosion factor how much
can this can these crops prevent erosion
and
even potentially add to soil carbon
sequestration the economic piece of it
is to figure out what's the starting
point for for a grain prices for these
are they going to be commodity crops
that are just used similarly to other
grains in the market or are they going
to be in a niche market place in using
enterprise budgeting techniques to
quantify all of the inputs and then the
productivity of a system we can start to
understand what the price point for a
perennial grain would be and then where
it might fit into a food system finally
we're going to evaluate system-wide
environmental sustainability by
quantifying all of the inputs and
outputs of the system and then comparing
them with annual crops to see what the
benefits might be here so all of this is
being done in a with using data from a
field experiment that was established at
Musgrave research farm the fall of 2016
we're comparing two perennial grains the
Kern's the intermediate wheatgrass and
ace one perennial rye so a warthog
winter wheat and two varieties of winter
malting barley in a randomized complete
block design and the treatment of frost
seeded medium red clover so just a side
about red clover we're interested in
intercropping and interceding in the
sustainable cropping systems lab
increasing the biodiversity of
agricultural system and looking for
complementarity between different
species of plants and so legume inter
crops with with grass is a very commonly
used mixture there's complementarity
there with the legumes fixing nitrogen
to allow the grasses to grow better
legumes can also provide weed
suppression they can moderate the soil
climate increasing soil moisture and
reducing evaporation and they can
contribute to a more diverse and soil
microbiota so we chose medium red clover
as legume we're going to inter crop in
our systems due to previous work they've
been done with alfalfa white clove or
sweet clover that showed that Kern's in
particular being a very competitive
grass would out-compete some of the the
other legumes and medium red clover is a
little bit more vigorous we seeded it at
a relatively high rate in order to try
to overcome that competitive effect and
it seems to have worked I'll show some
slides about that but it might be hard
to see here but in one of our split
plots you can see the side with clover
in it being just a little bit more green
on the side without and the same thing
happened with Kern's ahir clover and
then no clover so in fall
tene it was established just some
details about a false seed bed was used
to reduce weed pressure applied a target
of 75 kilograms of nitrogen split
between fall and spring and then just
some seeding seeding rate details
seeding rates were provided by the
perennial grain breeding programs that
received seed from and the annuals were
based on information from our farmer
Advisory Board of local organic grain
farmers so to look at what it looked
like in fall 2016 Kern's they did not
look great and it's something we've
learned that it is a little bit slower
to establish and it takes off in the
following spring but it was a little bit
worrisome at the time our wheat and
barley looked fine the Rye was a little
bit patchy but that also did show in
moving forward to the first harvest we
did have a couple of issues as I said
the Kearns
did fill in but maybe not at the stand
density we would have liked
barley had some winterkill issues in
that first year which is actually why we
switched our variety of barley into the
second year to a more winter hardy
variety and there were some significant
lodging problems with the ace one rise
is a six six and a half foot tall crop
and we may have seated at a high rate
there may be other factors influencing
this but in some pots lodging was as
high as 60% in our second
serviced you'll notice in particular
that in the rye with clover
there was a persistence issue we lost
almost all the rye in that in that
second overwintering where there was no
clover there was some rye but it was
still not enough to combine so this is
one of the major things to be aware of
in terms of certain perennial crops
there their persistence is important if
they're going to be part of a productive
system we did figure out how to grow
barley a little bit better in the second
year and then Kern's ax did regrow quite
vigorously although we did notice that
its reproductive bigger was a little bit
lower in the second year that's
something that's been found in other
projects with these grains that their
yields do decline over time with the age
of the stand so now I'll go into some
preliminary results so for our first
objective looking at agronomic
productivity we collected biomass
samples in 2017 and 2018 and 1/2 meter
squared quadrats we separated crop
biomass from weed biomass and then
separated the crop biomass into stems
and seed heads we did look at components
of yields from a subsample of those seed
heads one thing to mention about Kern's
is that doesn't need to be d hold and we
also harvested a strip from each of
these plots using a al Meiko plot
combine so to look at stand density in
2017 and 2018 barley was low due to
winter kill Kearns is consistent across
the two years rye we're seeing
particularly with clover in the second
year was very low density and otherwise
reasonable stem counts we are seeing
some effect perhaps of clover reducing
stem density in certain certain cases
but we'll look at how that's affecting
yield in a couple of slides
terms of crop biomass we did find that
the perennials uh do produce quite a
large amount of crop biomass and since
they phenology is different they are
green later into the season that might
be an avenue for a dual purpose forage
and grain crop we also did see that
Kearns that maintained this biomass
production across both years while rye
which was extremely productive in the
first year again not persistent enough
for crop system and then grain yields
what many people are interested in
significantly lower yields for the
perennials compared to the annuals and
in turns oh we're seeing a decline of
about fifty percent in that at second
year and rye we weren't able to harvest
anything we did notice however the the
benefit of of clover in the grain in
particular for the annuals in this
second year so that seems to be a
nitrogen effect so to summarize these
agronomic results we really need to
address the per any allottee of a swan
or it won't be an effective part of a
perennial cropping system interceding
red clovers seem to be a benefit to the
system use of the perennials to produce
forage might be part of making these
more economically viable and we will be
doing grain and forage quality a
assessment and then yield improvements
through breeding and cropping system
optimization are necessary in order for
these to compete with annuals in terms
of productivity if we want to actually
achieve those food security goals
terms of understanding pest dynamics
we looked at we'd comp community
composition based on those same biomass
samples taken in twice I'm teen and 2018
weeds were sorted by species dried and
weighed and then in collaboration with
Mike Fulcher in the Bergstrom lab we
scouted for disease and took disease
samples in 2017 and 2018 cultured those
in the lab and also looked at effects on
grain quality from fungal pathogens in
terms of weed biomass we did see low
weed biomass in the wheat and rye in the
first year and tended to be an increase
in in weed biomass from year one tier
two in in rye the the weed biomass
increased dramatically and Kern's it in
no significant difference in weeds from
year one to year two but it was quite a
bit there we also did see a suppressive
effect of clover and actually one thing
you're seeing with these is that if you
added the clover biomass back in a total
non grain biomass of the crops would be
higher than it than it looks here so the
competitive effect of the clover in the
rise actually what we believe
contributed to the extremely low stand
density there we also have done a
community ordination so I'll spend a
little time explaining this this is a
way to visualize the difference between
different communities of plants by
extrapolating the statistical difference
between abundance and and of different
plants in different samples so how to
interpret this is that we have our grain
crops barley being the square Kern's of
the circle is one rye the triangle and
wheat as the diamond and those are
plotted for each plot and then we also
have the weed species codes showing the
similarity or the likelihood that that
weed species is relative to that plot in
terms of distance
so the closer a weed species code is to
a certain plot the more likely it was to
be there and the more abundant it was
within that pot we've also separated
this between the first year which is
these lighter colored shapes for the
plots in the second year which is the
black shapes and we are seeing a
separation between those so there were
more species and more annual species in
the first year compared to the second
year and then looking at these ellipses
that indicate the the confidence
interval of each crop year interaction
we have we have the first year of wheat
the first year of barley the first year
of rye and the first year of Kearns ax
and so they are overlapping quite a bit
down here in the second year we did see
that the annuals were starting to
separate more from the perennials and
what species were president in those
plots and their abundance there so just
to highlight which is which so you can
compare the green as Kearns oh the red
is rye the yellow and brown is wheat and
the blue is barley or disease working
with Mike we observed a number of
pathogens in ace one and Kern's ax in
particular many in in Kern's ax this is
it quite a laundry list for a single
year's worth pathogens and we even found
one pathogen thar spot which is most
common in corn not really been seen in
small grains so there there could be an
even a higher diversity of pathogens to
be worried about with some of these
perennials we did find that there were
relatively high vomitoxin levels and
some of the grains so this is a concern
and an issue that needs to be addressed
the USDA recommendation for vomitoxin is
one part per million so in both cases we
were above that on average
so to summarize perennial grasses and
certain rosamma
this dicots are likely to dominate our
perennial systems and we were seeing
that in the second year of our weed
assessment in particular clover can
provide weed suppression the weed
control during the establishment year is
what we believe to be critical you have
seen with some perennials that if they
if they get off the ground and become
competitive close the canopy that we has
really aren't a problem there perhaps
even with rye one thing we're
considering is post harvest weed control
we noticed that after harvesting the Rye
in the first year that other species
came right into that space and without
any control in the fall it may not have
been able to store enough resources to
overwinter successfully so we'll be
looking at that in the future we have
looked at many pathogens and we've seen
some fungal contamination are there
impacts on on grain yield something to
be looked into the future the vomitoxin
contamination is concerning and
developing integrated pest management
strategies for use in perennial grain
systems where certain tech crop rotation
cultivation are not available should be
a priority in order to make these
effective systems in terms of soil
health we sampled in three years just
after planting and then just after
harvest in 2017 and 2018 took aggregate
soil cores from each plot and retained
about a kilogram for analysis calculated
bulk density used LICO for nitrogen and
carbon analysis and did permanganate
oxidizable carbon soil respiration and
aggregate wet aggregate stability in the
Cornell soil health lab don't have any
data on that to present at this time but
the in the literature ferns that has
been shown to improve indicators of soil
health but not necessarily storm or soil
carbon than than wheat over a period of
four years in 29
tene we're gonna conclude our soil
sampling by doing a depth stratified
sampling to maybe take a closer look at
the soil carbon dynamics we'll be doing
some field measurements of Road ability
with rainfall simulators and universal
soil loss equation modeling to determine
the difference between the treneil and
annuals I do have these two pictures
which were taken at Musgrave in April of
2017 showing after a 2 inch rainfall
event and a span about three hours some
gully erosion that occurred in an
adjacent wheat field and little to no
evidence of significant erosion and the
currents of field right next to it and
for a sense of scale the surveying pens
about a foot long so there was six to
eight inches of soil loss in this field
and that one rain event and with the
intensity of these types of extreme
weather events the frequency intensity
of them increasing this is a major
concern and a major benefit of perennial
crops for the economic analysis we did
we're planning on doing full enterprise
budgets for but for the purpose of this
presentation was only able to get two
partial budgets so the benefits are the
variables that were considering include
Field Operations land rental prices seed
fertilizer and then the production of
grain and and biomass for forage or
straw we will be conducting sensitivity
analysis to look closer at the yield
over time using that present value to
estimate the break-even point of these
perennial crops in terms of how long
they're in the ground we will look at
weather price premiums for perennial
products how that influences the
economics of it and what if the
increases to yield of perennials that's
coming down the pipeline in terms of
breeding or even optimization of our
cropping systems can can play a role
there as well
so just for our preliminary results with
the partial budgets what we did was we
compared Kern's and ace one so we in
terms of the the costs and then the
receipts from each system and then we
looked for a total revenue and then used
a goal seeking algorithm to come
chain basically change the prices that
we were putting in for Kern's ax and Ace
one until they matched the revenue
available from week to get that
break-even price and so you can see some
of the costs are different in particular
the tillage and planting and seed costs
in the years after that first
establishment year for the perennials
and that could be a piece of changing
the the profit margins on these
perennial grants compared to annuals so
what would be fine very high prices for
the perennials at this point you to
those low yields three dollars a
kilogram is very high I will say it for
Kern's although when Patagonia was
sourcing the Kern's ofor their initial
long root L product they were paying
over $1 a pound for Kearns ax for that
so this isn't too far off of what
somebody actually paid for these
products in terms of getting it into
their their their their prep their
processing in terms of running a few
sensitivity analyses this was done to
see what yield Kearns and rye would need
to produce if they were valued at the
same price as organic winter wheat and
we're seeing that the the yields are a
little bit lower than what you would
expect from typical organic wheat field
about four thousand kilograms and the
prices do decrease if you assume that
the perennial yields stay steady over
time future work will include expanding
these two full enterprise budgets to
look more at the margins and then more
modeling and research into the food
value chain of where these crops will be
produced process
and then sent to market
our last objective looking at
system-wide environmental sustainability
we'll be using two different analyses
the first is emerge-ii or embodied
energy which looks at all of the inputs
to a system including natural resources
such as solar radiation rainfall wind
energy for pollination and the soil
that's supporting the system and then
transforms all those values into a a
common unit for comparison across
systems and calculates to certain
sustainability indices based on the
ratio of renewable resources to
non-renewable resources that are used
therein we'll also be using the farm
energy analysis tool which is a static
model that was developed to estimate
greenhouse gas emissions and fuel usage
within farming systems and that's based
on parameters such as type of tillage
the crop area and yield residue
management and removal and some certain
inputs such as fertilizer rate seeding
rate pesticides and fuel consumption
just to wrap up I will mention a couple
of our other projects that are going on
that aren't necessarily going to be into
my thesis we are looking at
intercropping peas with these these
grains and also looking at other
agronomic factors such as nurse crops
and row spacing and this in this project
we are looking at how to renovate an
older current and to try to stimulate
new reproductive growth and one way that
we thought about that is to use strip
tillage for root zone disturbance and
increase encourage increased tillering
thereafter and this has shown some
promising preliminary results using fall
strip tillage and then allowing it to
regrow through the fallen into the
spring
and then finally looking at more closely
at the yield components of Kern zone
it's a multi-site project here Minnesota
Wisconsin and Kansas to understand the
development of the crop in different
climates and different regions and
relate that back to more important
agronomic considerations such as harvest
timing and processing so like to
acknowledge many many people that have
contributed to this work and
particularly my committee members 20
ditomasso Matt Ryan and Miguel Gomez in
applied economics and management all of
the lab members of the sustainable
cropping systems and weed ecology and
management labs many undergraduate
research assistants are farmer advisory
board and many external collaborators in
particular with the Kern's of projects
oh I think that's the wrong photo Thanks
[Applause]
with respect to the difficulty of
establishing tons of is that because the
seed viability is low or is it because
of some party dormancy or bigger well
since it's a very small seed relative to
our annuals it just takes a little bit
longer to get going in the fall it
doesn't grow as rapidly it doesn't have
the energy resources to do so and I
think in at musgrave part of our problem
is not unlike we're learning how to grow
these crops and things like seed
placement can be very important for a
smaller seeded species trying to target
it a half inch seeding depth and maybe
getting a little bit not having the
precision to place it right with some of
the equipment we're using there's also
some factor of soil moisture content and
how that could affect so it's a little
bit more sensitive to some of these
these variables so finding a way to and
it might involve seeding rate it might
involve not fertilizing in the fall
which some people have in currents of
research have shown to really just feed
the weeds the Kearns is not able to
uptake it it hasn't developed it's its
root system extensively enough to
fertilize to take fertilizer in that
first fall after planting working
through a lot of those questions will
probably contribute to enhanced
establishment and then we had control in
that period as well whether through
cultivation by planting in rows and then
cultivating in that first period before
it's able to spread into the rows or
using chemical methods for weed control
until it gets off the ground in the
following spring are some options that
we'll probably have to look at
Chuck mentioned the high vomitoxin
levels and I know some armored man shall
walk toxin levels but throughout a seat
thing mm-hmm and I wanted to take you
those levels were before around her so
those have not been cleaned and and
that's something that we've been
considering as whether there are
economic ways to remove the
contamination another way is to simply
blend with an other seed and I didn't
mention it with Kearns uh because some
some it's making practice properties it
is being used in in blend flour blends
for baking so it might not be as much of
a barrier but it's definitely something
that needs to be understood and managed
better it ideally there wouldn't be that
contamination
[Music]
yes so we are part of a group that has
been working on Kearns oh pretty closely
together and that involves both breeders
agronomists even food science folks at
the land Institute University of
Minnesota University of
wisconsin-madison
University of Manitoba here
Ohio State Iowa sorry Lyon in France so
there's there's an extensive research
Network around Kern's right now and the
main breeding efforts are happening at
the Land Institute Minnesota and
Manitoba and they are we're using what
they call cycle four Kearns ax in these
projects and the land Institute's now on
cycle eight and they're seeing 20%
averaging twenty percent yield increases
across those cycles so there has been
quite a lot of advancement in that and
it's even accelerating due to the use of
genomic selection rather than more
traditional phenotypic selection you can
imagine with a perennial where you might
need to grow it for five years in order
to actually phenotype it correctly that
that's a barrier to rapid breeding but
with with genomics they're accelerating
that process so the short answer is that
yes we're in contact with them we're
getting new varieties and seed we just
planted six new varieties at Caldwell
field this fall and we'll be evaluating
those varieties for the the north
eastern climate in collaboration with
others and hopefully that that will be a
big part in the progress of perennials
and making them a viable cropping system
so you mentioned the cruiser was
originally started at Rodale and then
moved to the land and those are real
different climates and soils the new
varieties have been selection pressure
during debriding development at any of
the
well that's what we're hoping to
discover with these new lines that we
receive this fall so we're we got four
lines from Minnesota and those are four
we would expect there would be some
difference based based on the the
selection in different climates so we'll
be comparing those with some of the land
institute varieties at the same time and
then seeing what comes out of that
yeah they've got lines that they're
going to have their own varieties pretty
soon
yeah
so you're comparing the perennial crops
with sounds like an organic annual crop
system in each case can you just say a
little bit more about that for what
you're comparing it to and how you chose
that
so why organic you know what kind of
rotation that says yeah so we we chose
to compare two organic small grains
because currently there aren't aren't
chemical weed controls or pesticides
that are labeled in in kearns our
perennial rye so we thought that would
be a good starting point
also Patagonia is 100% organic General
Mills Cascadian farms is an organic line
but their broader product line is not
and they actually are very interested in
conventional production just to increase
the scale that would be for them to get
enough grain for their products so that
that that was in that influenced our our
decision there were also the sustainable
cropping systems lab and a lot of our
work is into organic agriculture so
having some level of prior knowledge and
that was was a contributing factor there
but definitely looking into conventional
going forward is something that would be
needed to have this be as widespread as
it could be in terms of rotation we
realize that there is some artificiality
we're growing we after we after we in
the same plots you know in our
comparison so there's going to be in
effect there it's it's hard to so there
wasn't there was no rotation within this
this experiment in particular and we
think that there might have been some
disease buildup in in the wheat and
barley into the second year so that is
sort of a confounding effect but it's
without having massive experiments it's
hard to have enough variables to control
for everything that eat that you want to
so it was sort of a simplicity decision
there
Tony the Java question you answered it
was basically the road that you keep
returns in conventional systems and what
have you heard from growers are eight
open to money changers there's there's a
lot of people that are interested I
would say in terms of growers that are
looking to adopt some of these crafts
that's they might be a little bit too
early at this point there's there's
still work that needs to be done on the
other hand there is the the demand from
the food industry to have grain to work
with in their research and development
programs or even for I think Patagonia
is putting out a new currents of beer
pretty soon they even want to expand to
the east coast so that that is a sort of
an interesting time to live in as like
well from a research perspective I don't
think that we've quite figured it out
and I don't want to recommend a farmer
try this and then have it fail in their
fields but if there's an economic
incentive because of a high demand for
the product then there's there's that
consideration as well is one right or
serving as habitat for beneficial
insects pathogen non-pathogenic other
types organisms so I actually don't know
if any one that's that's looked at that
I can go back to one of my slides to
point out just a pretty cool thing that
we saw in one of the fields is that
there's birds nesting in our kearns a--
in relation to actually a wild parsnip
plant so we didn't want to get too close
to it but but it is it this is sort of
showing that that potential for an
enhance wildlife habitat by having it in
the ground year-round I will say Ducks
Unlimited has been in talks with the
land Institute about perennial grains as
a way to increase the the habitat
potential of cropland so that is another
possible benefit of these systems but it
hasn't been looked at very closely as
far as I know I mean when you talk about
systems I think about not only the
impact of the particular crop growing
it's impact others yeah so I know it's
outside the scope of your experiment but
within a landscape for example if you
have so much proportion of these
burnheal grains how much could they
affect positively the other annuals like
a growing area with respect to customs
so that's one my question here is do you
know anything about so that the
declining yield so the the theory is
that the life history of the plant is to
reproduce more seed when it's younger
and then as it ages trail off that part
of our reason for looking at strip
tillage is it could also be interest to
Civic competition or signaling between
plants saying okay this space is full
now we're not going to produce as much
seed we're going to focus on developing
deeper root systems and and competitive
strategies like that so I think that it
could be a little bit of both it could
just be the lifecycle of the plan it
could be that that competitive effect
that's affecting it but if we can better
understand that and even manage it that
would contribute to a more persistent
stainable system
Christine I know you've been thinking a
lot about herbicide resistance which is
the big problem in annual crops do you
expect there to be a shift if there was
widespread adoption of perennial greens
do you think that would affect
resistance this is one of my personal
opinion but I've been thinking about a
little bit of how to incorporate
chemical weed control into perennial
systems and I actually think that there
could be some real benefits there as
well because of the idea that if they
get past establishment and established
well then they'll out-compete other
weeds so in the five-year projected
lifespan of occur in the field you could
spray once or twice in that first fall
in spring to clean up the weeds that are
there and then for the next four years
not have to spray anything which you
could obviously you're reducing the
amount of product that's being applied
to the field and thus reducing Selective
pressure for herbicide tolerant weeds
and if we're going to be looking at the
seed bank and the spring it could have a
an effect on the seed bank if if other
seeds are from other weed species are
our fatal germinating underneath they're
fatally germinating so and not necessary
related to your question but in terms of
organic which it has been I think that
there's potential for certain farmers to
transition to organic using perennial
crops where you could use your sort of
final dose of herbicide and that
establishment and then the next four
years know herbicide application keep
your records and by the end of it
there's organic certification on the
line as well so I think there's
potential in those those areas too but I
do think that work on herbicide efficacy
and the the impact on the on the crops
finding viable herbicides would move
along a lot of perennial grain systems
conventional systems hasn't really been
done so far
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu